with video cameras presumably running
non-stop they substituted pieces of
medieval linen for pieces of the shroud
so why didn't the cameras pick it up
hogar Kirsten as a theory sees a gonza
Jose do artists optionals
off video film the entire process was
videotaped and I'm certainly the only
person on this planet who watched every
frame of the whole 8-hour procedure it's
all wonderfully documented except for a
missing half an hour it turns out that
the cameras were turned off when the
shroud pieces were taken to another room
and put into three containers one for
each lab
mind if I get my question of course was
since they were documented everything
why wasn't this part document I just
though it was after all a critical
moment the reason given for turning off
the cameras so that the labs wouldn't be
able to tell the shroud piece from the
control samples but the labs already
knew which piece belong to the shroud
because it was never D threaten and
Karstens conclusion in reality some kind
of manipulations must have taken place
in their manipulations as in pulling a
fast one by carefully examining the
photos of the shroud pieces and the ones
the lab received Kirsten has deduced
that a switch must have taken place
according to him the samples don't match
either by weight or appearance Jesus it
psyched these are exciting this piece
shows the Oxford sample which was used
to perform the radiocarbon dating we can
identify the fold axis and we have the
zero thread at which point the weaving
pattern turns in a different direction
this coordinate system allows us to
compare the pieces like fingerprints
this one is not identical to this one
but even if Kirsten is right it begs the
question why would the church resort to
deception to prove the shroud was
inauthentic Kirsten believes it was
because they were frightened of what the
shroud unwittingly revealed about the
crucifixion and it's aftermath
here's enviada Pluto Austin wounded here
we can see the bleeding from the wound
in the sides
the famous side wound which Longinus
made with his spear here we can clearly
see the strong flows of blood after the
body was laid in the horizontal position
and Kirsten thinks those blood flows are
a telltale forensic sign of Jesus's true
condition after the crucifixion